um I'm such a sucker for a specialist
whether it's a style vendor specialist
was striking specialist or Demian Maia
specialist I loved watching the guys
that are like at the tip of the the
ability in whatever their disciplines
and style bender man he seems to be
getting better every time yeah yeah well
for him it was just about avoiding
takedowns
like he was so high level as a kickboxer
he's so clever like he's he's like in my
opinion probably the very best in the
sport at setting traps yeah he'll I
gauge you see what you're doing is
getting some information yeah it's not
it's not random and I like the way he
deals with takedowns I mean he knows
where he's safe and where he's not you
don't see he's panicking is like a
minute let this cook a minute but yeah I
seen what I seen with this attempt looks
like I see what this one looks like
walking it through all right now my
party's gonna start yeah here's a guy I
talked to one of his guys he trains with
I was refereeing some fights in China
and it's one of the guys who trains with
in New Zealand and this guy was telling
me so much and showing me different
things about angles they do and things
that they set up and they're striking
that I'd never knew or thought about and
this was before I I saw him start
fighting in UFC
you know just what everybody was aware
of him but he hadn't been into the UFC
yet and man these guys these guys are
really smart these the the techniques
like this sport is growing so much you
know yeah yeah that's what I was saying
like when when you're seeing like really
high level super technical strikers like
him like who's a world-class Labine it's
good he easily could be world champion
in many organizations as a kickboxer you
see him now in the UFC and see guys
having to deal with that it's like okay
this is like the Anderson fight it's a
great example we know how great Anderson
is yeah I still look pretty good against
Nile bender but you could see why style
bender was special enough yet did he I'd
like another level of trickery yeah you
know and I mean then stuff John Jones is
doing mm-hmm yeah yeah but so you can't
call him a specialist because man he
does so many different sounds right it's
that guy it's really like a kung fu
movie right where he changed out there
yeah and then they do they do something
yeah yeah well John such a good kicker -
I mean that's that's interesting he
started out as a wrestler cuz like how
much of his style now is convenient it's
a giant part of his game his utilization
those long ass legs right and Indies
it's interesting like how how much time
he looks like he's getting information
on right yeah then all of a sudden the
end of them then when he shifts gears
it's like okay I've gotten a lot of
information here's nothing to do with it
yeah yeah he's gonna fight Thiago Santos
right yeah mm-hmm
that guy goes for broke I mean he goes
for broke it's it's interesting to watch
him fight because you want to talk about
like a wild reckless dude like Santos is
dangerous with John John should and
probably will be a heavy favorite but
Santos he does he throws something hey
make no no it's gonna be it's gonna be
it's a great fight to watch yeah that
guy's gonna go out on a shield no he and
he puts pressure I think the interesting
thing about well for me what's
interesting when I watch any of the
heavier guys fight is that you know they
really have to understand where they're
safe and whether or not that's something
that John does really good yeah how'd it
be in the pocket in the places where
he's safe and what you know and where's
yeah he's the best Everett utilizing his
reach like no one's ever been better at
controlling reach and then never letting
a guy reset when guys try to reset Bamie
kick some bammy kicks him again BAM he
kicks him yeah he's like he knows when
you're trying to get comfortable when
you're trying to settle in and that's
when he kicks you like he senses it
I just starts battering you he sees like
no no no brakes no brakes no brakes no
brakes no brakes like the angles no
brakes what about a man max Holloway oh
dude he's the king of no brakes
there's no brakes
Oh pours it on you just keeps coming
yeah